un bon matin tout le monde
le travail de cession de ses étudiants
en droit pourra avoir un impact sur
l'ensemble de la population québécoise
on sait que l'obsolescence pianiste un
phénomène qui datent pas d'il ya pris
une expansion de groupes de l'université
de sherbrooke rédigé un projet de loi
contre l'obsolescence programmée
c'est un problème qu'on donne à la
société puis qu'il faut ré nuit puisque
pour ça qu'avec le projet de loi ça ne
me gêne vraiment concret avec l'aide de
parlementaires indépendants et des
partis de l'opposition
les étudiants de sherbrooke veulent même
poussé le gouvernement a étudié et
adopté cette nouvelle législation dont
60 consoles de jeux vidéo exactement
xbox 360
martin masse répare toutes sortes
d'appareils électroniques depuis
plusieurs années or aucune vis j'aurai
besoin d'un outil tel ceux ci on n'est
pas dans un concept ou 1
on prend un tournevis et puis euh nan là
je commence à avoir un accès plus normal
le constat est clair l'objectif premier
du fabricant n'est pas de faciliter la
réparation quand même manufacturier
fabrique son produit est plus de dieu
puis il crée pas de réseau de
distribution de pièces par la suite la
pile est quand même une haute capacité
qui couvre pratiquement tous les
appareils et colis
ce qu'on veut faire c'est plutôt apporte
une loi qui demanderait aux manifs acte
huriez de rendre le produit plus
réparable
le connecteur de la pile est soudé à la
carte maîtresse les etats unis l'europe
présentement sont assez avancées sur des
lois qu'on appelle wright ou reaper donc
le droit de réparer alors si les soirées
québec et où le canada pourrait se
joindre à ce mouvement alors je pense
que ça pourrait peser beaucoup plus dans
le balancier quelque chose qui brisent
énormément smart hamas a été évité à
titre d'expert pour conseiller les
étudiants les gens sont tannés de
toujours renouveler la flotte
d'électronique aux deux âges parce qu'on
a passé cette étape là de
surconsommation partie iii se lit comme
suit les pièces et les outils de
réparation ne peuvent est ainsi offert
que moyen
raisonnable et des conditions favorables
à l'acheteur du bien le projet de loi
des étudiants proposent essentiellement
de moderniser l'actuelle loi sur la
protection du consommateur d'y ajouter
la notion de droit à la réparation le
droit à la réparation à qui que ce soit
c'est nous à nouveau ça c'est vraiment
ce que nous voulons c'est une notion on
n'a pas vu en déflation ou un peu de
repos on note on peut exiger le droit à
la réparation
le projet de loi propose aussi de créer
un indice de réparabilité d'afficher
clairement sur certains biens
s'il est possible ou non de les réparer
en plus la loi pourrait obliger le
fabricant a annoncé clairement quelle
est la durée de vie d'un appareil
ça va permettre à la loi de la garantie
légale d'arrêter d'être interprétée
parce que le présentement si on veut au
cour des petites créances et un juge qui
doit interpréter la durée de vie d'un
produit mais forcer les fabricants ne
sera pas facile
je très anxieux et énervé de voir
comment on va réussir à expliquer
comment demander aux grands
manufacturiers de produits des manuels
de réparation en plus il faut s'assurer
que le gouvernement accepte de mettre le
projet de loi à l'ordre du jour
l'essentiel du projet bas il faut que ça
soit supportée par lé un mouvement
populaire il faut qu'il ya un appui en
fait on a déjà sorti une pétition qui
est sur le site de l'assemblée nationale
qu'il trop facile à les signer les
citoyens ont jusqu'au 1er avril pour
signer la pétition pour faire pression
sur le gouvernement pour qu'il entende
ce projet de loi contre l'obsolescence
programmée
quel bon reportage bessac si clair la
volonté de ces gens là ils limpide
alors la question est ce que rooney sert
la justice on va prêter l'oreille on va
on va faire cette loi là dans le
gouvernement le go actuellement c'est
l'adjointe parlementaire de la ministre
de la justice sonia lebel qui a la
responsabilité du volet protection des
consommateurs et la députée lucie
lecours et leur rencontre et le groupe
d'étudiants de l'université sherbrooke
le 11 mars dernier
maintenant on attend du côté du
gouvernement que le projet de loi sera
officiellement déposée valeur par des
députés de l'opposition
le 9 avril est ce qu'on dit c'est que
par la suite à des fonctionnaires de
l'office la protection du consommateur
qui vont analyser chaque article et
ensuite eh ben on verra on verra selon
l'agenda et c'est pour ça patrice que
vous avez 11 mille cinq cents personnes
à peu près qui ont actuellement signez
la pétition sur l'assemblée nationale
pour que il ya d'autres y ait des suites
à cette affaire là que le gouvernement
ça tarde vraiment à ce problème là que
les gens constatent de plus en plus et
ce depuis assez longtemps très bien je
vous la livre est un plus petit l'on
veut le dire www.as emblée nationale
hasna pour assemblée nationale point
qc.ca l'insuccès s'intéresse à sa touche
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde
simplement chercher pétition
obsolescence programmée vous avez
facilement la trouve ça fascinant cet
homme qui vous expliquez que tu fais pas
l'ouvrir la machine lui a fallu qu'ils
bidule d'aider un désastre pour défaire
des morceaux par la suite il a accès
c'est vraiment bien fait très bien à la
merci mais ça
au revoir